yeah at this
point so
hey Ria how is your IND
trip you still jet lag or
no but you probably would fall asleep in
the night class anyway right is nothing
to do with India
so okay
folks um at the risk of
at the risk of pulling off scabs of
wounds your quizzes are upstairs waiting
to be picked up waiting and waiting and
waiting I will leave them out there till
they become recycling so it's it's in a
sense it's out of my room I want it out
of my room but somewhere in the next two
weeks I will bring it in so I will leave
it out there for a while and if you
can't find your quiz it's because
somebody's been playing with the
alphabetical it was in perfect
alphabetical order yesterday it's not in
imperfect alphabetical order anymore
I've already resorted it
twice and I'm done so at this point it
is what it is so you
know but remember it's
10% it can be a throw we quiz if you did
it badly it can be a keep quiz if you
did it well but don't overplay it right
so if you did well great you did badly
it's okay there's more to come So today
we're going to talk about the biggest
number somewhere after we talk a little
bit more about growth the biggest number
in evaluation which is your terminal
value number it's a number that if you
don't pay attention to can very quickly
take over your valuation and drive it to
ruin all that work you put coming up
with the earnings and the cash flows and
the growth for the first 10 years gone
in a second So today we're going to put
you know what I call guard R in terminal
value so you can you can decide what you
can or cannot do and there are a whole
lot of things you cannot do once you get
to the terminal value calculation so I'm
going to start that discussion today
with a question that we're going to come
back and talk about more so you
projected out cash flows the next five
next 10 years you get to your 10 why do
we have terminal value because we need
closure we can't estimate cash flows
forever you're trying to come up with
the terminal value which of the
following is never an appropriate choice
to get terminal value right so three of
the four obviously are okay is
liquidation value okay for a term
value brance what do you think you think
so let's say valuing um a business run
by a 70-year-old
plumber right and his son has moved on
Works somewhere else and his practice is
kind of going to die with them you
project out the cash flows first you
have to check the Actuarial tables to
see how long it lives 10 years and then
at the end of year 10 what are you going
to
do speci situation is it that special
there are 90 times more valuations of
personal businesses than are public
companies right in those businesses
liquidation value actually makes sense
because the or take a ramco at the end
of 50 years you get all the oil out of
the ground how much is the are the Saudi
sand worth nothing
right liquidation value is a perfectly
appropriate way of doing things we don't
do it with publicly traded companies
because not because there isn't a
liquidation value but because a going
concern value might be higher than the
liquidation value right every business
is a liquidation value for some the
liquidation value might be higher that's
okay how about a stable growth
model that's what we do all the time
right saying isn't that the only way to
get terminal value well I mean it's in
some textbooks it's presented as the
only way can I get to your 10 and make
it a growing anity you know what I mean
by growing inity rather than assume cash
flows continue forever I assume they
continue for another 15 years think it's
okay uh I yeah yeah what so tell me the
kinds of companies we are more likely to
take that path than the cash flows in
perpetuity um companies that might have
technology in the future that might in
fact you see the the technology we're on
right now recording this class Zoom
great technology but if you think we're
going to be sitting around 60 years from
now on Zoom you have a very different
perspective on this is a technology it's
a great technology it to shall fade
you're valuing Zoom you get to your 10
you're going to get this scaling up
effect and then there's no forever 10 15
years and you're done that's okay so I
kind of LED you to the one thing you
should never
do which 80% of banking valuations do
all the time which is you get to your 10
how do you get terminal value you apply
a
multiple private Equity same thing you
think what's wrong with it there's
nothing wrong with you made your biggest
value in your intrinsic value into a
forward pricing right this is a forward
pricing dressed up to look like a
discounted cash flow
valuation if we're going to have a
forward pricing let's have an honest
discussion about the forward pricing
don't give me this front end of a DCF
model fool me with cash flows and growth
rates and discount rates for the next 10
years when I know the biggest number
using is eight times down year 10 which
you got by looking at some pure group
you invented
why do we think why do you think Bankers
like exit multiples so
much because they're pricers the game is
a pricing game where making them play
this discounted cash flow story when in
fact hey you're a banker just take the
DCF out of there let's St pricing let's
do it right so a lot of discounted cash
flow valuations out there are really not
discounted cash flow valuation they're
forward pricing with a front end of cash
flows yes
because I think we're all supposed to do
it because you know it's become this
right of hey you are a deep person you
got to do DCF shallow people do pricing
so here's how I show I'm a deep person I
do cash flows I do discount rates I know
what a free cash flow is your heart's
not in it and at the end of the process
you're working back to whatever you need
to pay I understand the incentives that
drive you there but think of how much
time you spend on that cash flow front
the weeks you spend with sleepless
nights trying to the free cash FL on
your one knowing fully well it doesn't
really
matter now let's make this about a
Perpetual growth model let's say you're
looking at a business it's already in
stable growth it's got a 100 million and
after tax operating income no growth in
perpetuity and it cost a capital of
10% RI what's the value of this business
business Nikita help out Ri so we have a
cash flow constant cash flow forever
discount rate of
10% since we don't have a grow wait do
you not have a reinvestment number what
did I give you as a growth
rate 0% how much do you need to reinvest
to get 0% growth 0% this is one of the
few cases we can actually take after tax
operating income in three free cash flow
it's it's not that so basically the zero
growth means zero reinvestment you
numerate is therefore 100 Mil it's a
free cash flow to the firm denominator
is 10% the value of this business is a
billion dollars everybody agree this is
the McKenzie model for terminal value
where you have no plat in the numerator
and growth in the denominator we talk
about what McKenzie assumes to get you
there a billion dollars and you're not
happy why are you not happy you wanted a
bigger number so I'll give you a pathway
let's suppose you put in a two % growth
rate into this
story what's going to happen to the
terminal value
what I'm going to let Michael jump in
What do you think will happen Michael
it's going to mathematically it should
go up right because in the denominator
now you have 10% minus 2% what's in your
numerator
though it can't be 100 million still
because to get to that 2% growth rate
what do you need to do you need to
reinvest how much do you need to
reinvest here's where the magic of
sustainable growth kicks in
right because if your return on capital
is
10% you have to reinvest 20% of your
after tax operate income how do it come
up the 20% 2% divided by the 10% try
this out take your numerator take 20%
off divide by R minus C guess what your
terminal value is going to do absolutely
nothing it's going to stay exactly the
same why because your return on capital
is equal to the cost of capital it seems
like magic when you ear exactly your
cost of capital If This Were a capital
budgeting project what's your npv going
to be zero what happens if you take a
project with an npv is zero zero what if
the thousand times zero zero right
growth becomes just running in place so
today we're going to know because people
often talk about the growth rate in the
terminal value being the big deal you
can already see that's not the real big
deal it's what do you assume about
excess returns in perpetu so we've
already started to put some guard rails
in on Terminal value we'll come back and
talk about them but I want to go back to
where I left you on the growth
discussion I was in that long and very
boring discussion of retention ratios
times I they Bor I mean I was bored I
don't know how you were not bored if you
you know so I fully understand if you
bored as well but in sustainable growth
we look at two questions how much you
you reinvesting how well are you
reinvesting and we talked about growth
in earnings per share retention ratio
times return Equity we then looked at
growth in net income where you looked at
Equity reinvestment rates and retention
ratios Rich measure of how much you're
reinvesting and a non-cash return Equity
let's move One Step Up the Ladder you
want to get a growth in operating income
you measure how much you reinvest with a
reinvestment rate what's a reinvestment
rate you take net capex and change in
working capital with all the kavat the
things we count in there right R&D and
Acquisitions and you divide it by after
tax operating income notice a pattern
here whenever you're looking at Equity
we focus on what percentage of net
income you put back here we look at the
percentage of after tax Opera income and
when we look at how well we invest we
look at return on invested Capital our
perspective is about the entire business
and again the sustainable growth
equation is your reinvestment rate times
your return on Capital
is your expected growth
rate so I'll take you back in time this
is 1999 Cisco was on top of the world
very similar to where Nvidia is right
now right the architecture of the
internet and it had phenomenal
fundamentals in fact the reinvestment
rate was 107% remember those
Acquisitions that Cisco did pushed up
the reinvestment rate but what was
impressive is the return on Capital they
were delivering again accounting numbers
to the degree I trust them 34% return on
Capital you reinvest 107% you have a 34%
return on Capital your expected growth
rate would be
36% so sitting in 1999 looked eminently
reasonable right one of the great
companies of the 1990s so what do you do
you projected these numbers for the next
10 years what went
wrong anybody yeah they can't keep well
they were already big so the 106%
reinvestment rate got more and more
difficult they tried to keep growing at
that rate but the return on Capital very
quickly started to drop back down from
36% down to 10% Cisco did exactly what
they did in the 1990s in the following
decade but with very different
consequences instead of creating value
they were just running in place Cisco's
market cap in 2010 was roughly what it
was in 2000 same management team same
model for growing and this is something
we're going to come back and talk about
with Acquisitions Acquisitions are
almost a Time Decay strategy they work
but there's a point in time where they
stop working because you become too big
to keep doing
it so underlying all these sustainable
growth models is an accounting return
right return and Equity return versus
capital and I think I've come across as
skeptical about accounting numbers and
I'm using the word skeptical to
understand what I really feel it
terrifies me every time I compute these
numbers it terrifies me even more when I
hear Consultants using these numbers to
drive company
decisions because I've been in the
kitchen and you don't want to see the
return invest Capital made if you're
interested I I shouldn't say if you have
trouble sleeping at night I think I have
a
solution I a paper I wrote on accounting
returns return Equity return for scaff
that was so incredibly boring I fell
asleep multiple times while I was
writing the paper so if you read this
paper two pages and you're sleeping like
a baby I did this in Portugal I couldn't
go to sleep I read my own paper three
pages in jetl gone it's almost like my
body said I'd rather go to sleep than
listen to you read me this scrap but
here's what I did I took that accounting
return Capital which fundamentally looks
like a simple equation right after tax
operate income divided by Book value of
debt plus book value of equity minus
cash only place in finan as I said we
hold on to book value and then I started
looking at all of the things accountants
could do that SK that could skew return
on Capital starting with two we've
already talked about leases and R&D the
main reason we capitalize leases and R&D
is to get a better sense of invested
Capital return invested
Capital when a company takes a
restructuring charge think of what they
do to your invested Capital what happens
to your invested Capital right after the
restructuring charge it drops right so
if I'm not aware you've done that and
are you computed return Capital the next
year I'm going to end up with this
really high return on capital for the
company thinking it's taking great
projects when in fact it's been writing
off its mistakes so this entire paper 64
pages is about taking what accountants
do and working it through which
effectively means to get the return on
capital for last year for a company I
can't just take the accounting numbers
I've got to clean up for it but at the
end of the process you can get an
accounting return on Capital how much
you trust it will probably vary across
firms if you have a firm that's
primarily intangible in its Investments
the return Capital becomes shakier
because you had to capitalize things you
had to bring them in older
firms return invested Capital becomes
less trustworthy because the older
assets become the less Book value
actually captures what you originally
invest so with all of those caveats it's
still true that the return on Capital
becomes this driver and the return on
Capital we're talking about for the
future it's not the accounting return
cap for the past is what you think a
company will make on its future projects
one final piece of this sustainable
growth and then we'll put it to sleep
everything we've talked about so far is
when you have a return on Equity of
capital that's stable 12% but if your
return on Capital changes and we talked
about this a little in the last session
you get this efficiency effect I'll take
a very simple example let's suppose you
have a company with the return on
capital of 10% it reinvests nothing but
it doubles its return on Capital next
year dixa what's his growth rate going
to be next year if you go from 10%
return on Capital to 20% return on
Capital 100% 100% right you see that's
amazing but it's done you you get to 20%
unless you can go to 40 and then 80
you're kind of stuck efficiency growth
basically means as you work your way
towards that end game you can get this
efficiency growth adding on this is why
you can't use it in the terminal value
calculation is a justification for
growth because you can't keep growing by
just making yourself more efficient over
time so as you go through time you are
making assumptions on return on Capital
and
margins so take everything we've talked
about so far because I'm going to give
you five companies all of whom are
growing at the same rate and I want you
to rank them in terms of the quality of
growth quality in the sense as an
investor which of these growth rates
creates the most value and which one's
the least so you look across the five
companies they all have 10% growth but
they get there in very different ways
the first three firms get there by with
different combinations of reinvestment
rate and return on
Capital the last two get a supplementary
growth from improving that return on
Capital so if you're looking at the 10%
growth rate which one is a complete
freebie growth
here look at firm five all of the growth
is efficiency growth but it's just just
for one year if you look at in terms of
present value it's one and done and then
after the first year you're going to go
to 0% growth rate but if you look at
long-term growth which of these firms do
you rank most highly and why
Gabrielle you going all of them grow at
10% but when you grow remember we're
also looking at how much you have to put
back into the business to grow
so is it the reinvestment or the other
half of the pz remember it's return on
Capital times reinvestment rate gives
you growth rate based on the
reinvestment you're right the low
reinvestment is what you want it comes
from having a really high return Capital
firm one is clearly a winner 10% growth
very little reinvestment you can get 80%
of your earnings as cash flow still grow
10% a year in contrast look at firm
three it's growing at 10% but every time
it grows at 10% it actually makes itself
less valuable because it's earning well
below the cost to Capital so when you
look at return on Capital versus cost to
Capital you're getting a very quick
proxy on is this company growing and
creating value which is what what firm
one is doing nothing for Value which is
firm two or destroying value in firm
three
other yeah I'd rather in fact I would
rather The Firm three shrink right if
you can get out of this business all the
more power to you so I've said I've
never understood airlines that tried to
grow I can understand that Airline
that's stuck in place can't get out but
an airline that's growing what's what
Universe are you in what business are
you looking at I'm not seeing any of the
numbers there company like Indigo right
fastest growing Indian airline basically
doubled its size I don't know whe this
is a disaster waiting to happen or
whether they've some found some new way
in which they can earn more than the
cost of capital long term maybe they
have so when you look at growth that's
basically the end game
so now let's talk about the most generic
definition of growth because I'll wag
and none of you in this class is going
to be use able to use a sustainable
growth equation for the next 10 years
because things will be changing margins
returns so I'm going to look at the
broadest possible way to think about
free cash flow in the future this is
what my simp fcff simple Ginsu
spreadsheet is built on but I want to
take you input through input so you sit
down to Value company if your margins
are changing you have no choice but to
forecast Revenue do you see why cuz the
margins are changing you can't do
operating income too much stuff is
happening it's Revenue growth we're
going to talk about what it is that will
allow some of you to be able to use high
Revenue growth rates and others not to
be able to get
there then we're going to take a stop at
margins essentially the profitability of
business again some of you going to be
able to Aspire for much higher margin
than others we'll talk about the
economics of what drives us
and third you got to reinvest to get
that growth and because the growth is in
revenues I'm going to tie the
reinvestment to the change in revenues
I'm going to use a very simplistic
ratio what I call sales to Capital it's
like the return invest in capital but
I'm looking at Revenue to invest in
capital to see how much revenue I get
per dollar of capital investment those
are the three big numbers that drive
every
valuation let's look at what are the
factors that will allow you to kind of
give companies different numbers so I
want somebody body who wants to take
that in fact you can get started your
valuation you haven't done it tell me
what your company is and we'll use the
framework to think about can we give
this company high growth low growth
anybody want to be Guinea P okay who you
doing on okay good on is a great example
on of course makes you know a niche
footwear
company so first stop is revenue growth
there are two numbers I need I need to
get a sense of the total market and what
share of the market my company will get
it'll be nice if the total Market itself
is growing right because that gives me
more room to grow first What's the total
Market that on is going
after footware market perhaps a sub
subset of it athletic footwear because
they're not obviously competing against
Rockport or one of those so footware is
it a big
Market a pretty big Market in fact if
you wanted to estimate how big that
market is what's the way you're going to
do
it look at the revenues because most of
the companies Nike rebok Adidas are
publicly trade you add up the revenues
and you're going to get a market that's
that's large 250 billion 300 billion 400
billion how big is our On's revenues
right now 800 million so already you can
see you have a company that's that has
revenues of less than a billion the
market is 400 billion you have a lot of
room I'm not suggesting it's guaranteed
that you can grow but if you put in a
20% growth rate you know what Market's
big
enough let's say you valueing
Volkswagen what's the automobile market
look like it's
big but it's mature right in fact you
know if you think of it as gas powered
automobiles it's probably going to
shrink because electric cars are going
to take away more of the market
Volkswagen already has the largest or
the second largest market share of the
market so it's a large portion of a
state a mature Market you give 20%
growth rate for Volkswagen I have some
questions right because that basically
means you're wiping out Toyota you're
wiping out BMW and I don't see a
Universe where that is going to be
sustainable so you're looking at the
total Market you're looking at the
growth in the market you're also looking
at your market share and if your market
share is Big you already start so let's
take a company like Nvidia let's take
the AI chip market I'll give you the bad
news first the bad news for NVIDIA is
they already have an 80% market share of
the market what's the good
news the chip Market is growing 40 50% a
year so even if their market share goes
from 80 to 60% their revenues are going
to grow at 25 30 35% a
year so when you're looking at your
company you're looking at the total
Market you look at how how fast it's
growing and what share of the market is
and you're making your best judgment to
make that judgment you also have to
factor in who you're competing against
right if you take on who's a
competition Nike it could be Reebok it
could be let's face it there are other
Niche companies entering the space as
well right because they see what on has
done say we too can do this so this is a
comparative market and what sets
companies apart in this
market what sets companies
apart brand name right so you're already
thinking about what kind of brand name
is on how many people recognize it how
sustainable is this brand name is it
going to be like Croc source and then
kind of loses brand name and tries to
come back it's a fad driven business
there are very few companies that have
had brand names that have lasted the
reason we talk about Nike and Reebok and
Adidas is they're the long lasting ones
so you're looking at the market you're
looking at the market share looking at
the competition you think that's a lot
of things to look at it is the world we
live in right to value a company you
have to know what your company does any
questions on Revenue growth for any of
you you have you picked a company where
looking forward you might actually see
negative Revenue
growth what kind of give me an example
of a company we're looking at the market
and the market
share a what a gig based economy a gig
based economy that's a little too much
for me to wrap my head around but I'll
give you an let's say while anybody
Welling
Altria Philip Morris
right Tobacco Company dominates its
Market biggest market share but the
market itself is
shrinking I'm going to expect to see a
negative Revenue growth rate if you put
in a positive one you need a story right
what's the story they're entering the
vaping business they're entering the
Cannabis in fact the big question is
what's the biggest Advantage tobacco
companies have is they know how to live
in a world where everybody hates
them and essentially they found a way to
survive and prosper and deliver profits
and the the big cannabis company has to
have those characteristics as well
because it's only a matter of time
before we discover cannabis destroys
your brain cells and people start suing
you tobacco companies I've seen this
movie
before so if you give me a positive
growth rate you have to tell me what
other markets are entering so that's
first stop second stop oh as we do this
I'm going to take an example Airbnb went
public you know when it went public most
unusual IPO ever November of 2020 the
word was still partially shut down from
covid you have a hospitality company and
I think it actually made sense to them
to do it because a competition had been
H hammered so much more by covid that
their differential Advantage was
greatest so at that time I did
evaluation of Airbnb and I ran into a
prom What's the total market for
Airbnb it's Hotel business right anybody
traveling and renting a room and in
2019 collectively Hotel companies had
revenues of about 700 billion and it's a
very Consolidated Market the big names
Hilton so it's a business that's about
700 billion has about four or five big
names and Airbnb is entry so an Airbnb
filed its
Prospectors you know the the people
behind the company the founders the
owners the
you know part of writing the prospectus
said estimated that their total
addressable market and silicon values
become very clever about this total
addressable Market serviceable
addressable Market essentially a big
number 1.8 trillion no already that
gives you pause right hotels are 700
billion collectively around the world
you're telling me that there's going to
be 1.8 trillion and then they went
further that you add in experiences
remember there was talk at Airbnb that
host would add experience and you went
to San Diego and you rented one your
host would arrange all the nice
locations nearby never quite bought into
that notion of I trust an Airbnb host to
also be my city
guide but they said if you add that on
it's 3.2 trillion first when you look at
these total addressable markets Uber
when they went public estimated their
total addressable Market to be $52
trillion you know how they got there
they added every dollar people spent not
just on car service but in buying
automobiles on public
transit they basically took any anything
that anybody spent on Transportation
through it in there why do you think
VC's and companies want to throw this
big number out
there because when you think about
growth you think about hey Uber is only
at 100 billion it could be 5.2 so
there's a little gaming going on clearly
there is zero chance that airbnb's
potential Market is 3.2 trillion but I
do believe that it'll be greater than
700 billion why because there will be
people who travel to other places who
would not have in the old hotel business
but might now do it with Airbnb because
you could take a family stay in a
three-bedroom apartment basically not
pay what you do in a
hotel so when I valued Airbnb I did
assume a market potential that was
greater than 700 billion but well below
that total addressable Market but you
can see with young companies how this
become comes off in the starting point
what's the market I'm going after second
stop oh one more thing on market share
this is actually something you saw in
almost every Silicon Valley sales spit
the flywheel effect what it basically is
is an illustration of how as you get
bigger it gets easier for you to get
bigger you see this with Uber you saw
the Airbnb here's how the Airbnb
flywheel worked right you want to list
your apartment on a service where do you
list it you list on the service that
most people go to so Airbnb if it
becomes the biggest will end up kind of
pushing others up if you want to rent an
apartment what do you go you go where
everybody else is it's the same
Phenomenon with right share what that
effectively means is the end game here
and this might depress people is you
want have 15 different platforms you're
going to consolidate into two or three
it's already happened in the US there
only three places you can go to rent
apartments
Airbnb Expedia and vbo and Expedia owns
vbo so you basically have two places to
go and that's in a sense the problem
with these platform based businesses is
competition is essentially going to get
demolished and you're going to end up
with winner take all which means when
you value these business you can also
give them a much higher market share
from a valuation perspective so revenues
market share you're already thinking
about business economics size of the
market in making those judgments so
let's say you made those judgments so
with on ad they might decide to give
them 30% growth because they have a
strong brand name it's a niche business
it's going to grow now comes the second
stop you have to estimate what they will
make as margins and again let's go back
to basic
economics the biggest single driver of
whether you can have high margins or low
margins is unit economics something I've
talked about off and on through this
class what do unit economics measure
they measure how much you make on that
next unit you sell
if you have great unit
economics you're going to have high
operating
margins if you have terrible unit
economics you can't you can you can
never escape from that now you take a
software company you know why we can
give them 45 50% margins because the
unity economics are just amazing right
the next Unity cell cost you almost
nothing why does Nvidia have so much
higher gross margins than everybody else
in the business because they don't make
the chips they design the chips that are
essentially almost like a software
company they do the design tsmc makes it
they they price it higher so you're
looking at unit economics in your
company and saying hey good unit if
you're a manufacturing company I don't
care how good you are you're never going
to get to 40 50 60% margins you're going
to be shooting at 12 14 15% margin
second stop economies of scale every
company I ever talk to talk the
economies of scale they're going to be
economies of scale right but how do you
separate the wannab bees from the ones
that actually have what is the what
could you look at in the data that would
tell you whether your company truly is
economies of
SC Jacob what do you think there's a big
company in that same that operates the
same business and they so you're looking
AC crosssection is there something in
the cross time comparison that will take
what's the definition of economies scale
that costs are growing at a lower rate
than revenues right so if I gave you 10
years of financials on my company my
revenues grow at 11% a year my costs are
also growing at 11% a year I have no
business talking about economies of
scale the best giveway in economies of
scale is look at Revenue growth over
time look at cost over time and if you
have economies of scale what does it
mean when you project margins for this
company as they get bigger there'll be
this output pressure and margins
the unit economics economies of scale so
let's say your economies of
scale you're cutting cost down right
this is good for your margins before you
make that judgment what's the wild card
if you have three competitors are also
scaling up they're also reducing
costs your margins might not go up
because you'll have to cut prices to
keep up with them so competition matters
it's great to have economies of scale
and great Unity economics in a market
where you don't have much competition a
market with competition you know who's
going to walk away with the benefits you
and I as
consumers because it's going to get pass
through on the question of when will I
get there you know what I mean by when
will I get there I'm at 3% I think I can
get to 25% the numbers in a spreadsheet
say can I get there in your two you'd
rather get there earlier rather than
later right but to make that judgment
you have to first start with your
current number if your current number is
minus 55% my guess is you're not getting
to plus 25% in two years there's a lot
of work to do the second is what the
business model for this company is is it
focused on growth or is it focused on
actually becoming
profitable your worst case scenario is
you invest in a young Growth Company but
the management has completely forgotten
about the fact that they need to make
money all they do is scale up and get
Scaled up again I valued PTM and they
went public the biggest mistake I made
was I thought they were run by rational
people what was PM's biggest sales pitch
when they went public what made them
what was the most impressive number
about
pum 330 million people on their
platform that's the advantage Indian and
Chinese companies start off with right
330 million people oh my God I will
never get that no European payment
platform will get to 330 million because
that'll require every person in Europe
including the Childs and pets to be list
listed on the
platform that was the most impressive
thing but if you a payment processor
remind me again how you make
money when people transact on your
platform you keep a slice of it's called
the
takeway this is not something that
technology created credit card companies
this is basically so if you look at if
you use an American Express at a
restaurant you transact how much goes to
American
Express so the highest percentage of any
credit cards 3 and a half to 4% which is
one reason a lot of merchants don't take
American Express
right then you go to Master Guard one of
the great franchises of all time if you
see a company that's actually been able
to keep the competition away and still
manage to grow MasterCard is it they
make about 2 and a half% but it's huge
gross transaction value PayPal is about
2 to 2 and a half% as
well you know what the PTM take rate was
when they went
public
3% why because they were giving away I
made the mistake of actually putting the
PTM app on my phone because I wanted to
see what it was I had to take it off
very quickly because they kept sending
me free offers every day more free stuff
for you more free I don't want free
stuff but you can see how they get
people on the platform I'll give you
free stuff if Starbucks gave free lattes
would they sell a lot of lattes yeah
that's a terrible business model I
assume that now they had 330 million
people that the management of PTM would
turn their attention towards improving
the take rate and there are two things I
underestimate one is the capacity of
management to stay in denial because the
paytm management seems to have
absolutely no idea that profitability is
a part of a business model so you know
what they did when they had 330 million
they wanted to go to 400 million for
they not stop sending more free stuff to
me
and there's the second problem and this
I should have factored in more carefully
when I did my valuation alipay has a
take rate of 1.5 1.6% it's lower in Asia
than in Europe but India has a
particular problem if you're a Payment
Processing Company there is a free
Payment Processing service in India
UPI which a lot of people can use so
you're competing in somebody it's a
government structured Payment Processing
system you it's not going to be
completely good for a shopkeeper right
it's designed for you know for really
small businesses but it's there which
effectively means La as an anchor
pulling down the take rate my guess is
in steady state PTM is going to be lucky
to have a one 1.2 even if they do things
right the way they run they'll never do
things right so when you assess this not
only looking at the business model and
what the company is doing you're looking
at how focused the management is on
actually delivering profits the day I
was willing to look at Uber as an
investment was the day in 2019 when Dar
Kowski would just come in as CEO to
replace Travis gnik would leav in a
whole host of
Scandal he got in front of the Uber
employees and he said hey
guys we need to figure out a way to make
money and I dropped to my knees said
thank you God finally after 12 years of
scaling up and billions and billions of
dollars of capital you finally woke up
to that realization and you can actually
argue that Uber's been run differently
they're trying there Uber one where you
can actually get a membership they're
trying to make the model more sticky and
that's all you can do Uber is in my
portfolio bill it's in Bill amman's
portfolio I think part of it is they are
finally figuring out it's not adding
another city that I want you to do I
want you to take your existing cities
maybe shed some of the Cities you're in
maybe they're not worthy of being in and
think about ways of making money so all
of those things feed into your
margins so yes I'm thinking about the
the the payment companies like in Europe
there are many players they just up most
of them will not live right because
right now all they're doing is scaling
up going going to venture capitalist
raising more cap I'm bigger than I was
before you have to I mean I the blame
here has to go to V capitals who funnel
money to businesses encourage them to
scale up and never stop and ask the
question what business model are you in
if I'm a Founder I'm a tech person I
need somebody helping me on the business
model side right but these VES this it's
almost like that drug dealers feeding
you more drug scale up scale up scale up
and in fact you need addiction treatment
programs you say okay we scaled up
enough now come back to this program so
we can talk about making money it's a
different mindset right every day you
wake up how do I get more users how do I
get more subscribers and that's so you
I'll safely predict at the end of the
game this is a Consolidated business
they're going to be two or three players
no matter where you are there's a reason
credit card companies Consolidated the
way they did right if you had 50
different credit cards think of how much
trouble shopkeepers have figuring out
you pull out a credit card you've ever
seen it before whether in fact they can
trust the credit card it's a business
consolidate and Europe being Europe I'm
not sure when that cleaning up process
will be but there will be a cleaning up
process years they are keeping like
growing up but ultimately they have to
grow up they have to they have to go
through what I what I call the bits for
a moment right if you're Jewish you know
bit moment these companies need to grow
up they need to look you
know it's not like you grow up overnight
right after your B mitz but you know
it's a it's a ceremony say hey you know
what you're growing up you need to think
about more than what your after school
specials look like and I think these
companies need that barwidth you know
take take that moment more
serious so with the Airbnb in November
2020 here's what my numbers look like I
projected that when they were in steady
state the gross bookings when ultimately
Airbnb makes money when you book
something gross bookings would be $155
billion you know what Marriott's
revenues were last year 25 billion so
Airbnb will have six times more and the
reason I feel pretty comfortable is you
look at bookings.com or Expedia they
have big numbers because it's a
Consolidated
business so that's how I get the
revenues for the margins in steady state
I gave them 25% margins you think you're
making that up I might
have but here again I look not at hotel
businesses very different business model
I was lucky at two publicly traded
companies Expedia and booking.com out
there booking.com at 30% margins Expedia
at 8 to 12% margins you know why I was
surprised Expedia actually has a segment
of the business model where they buy
hotel rooms from hotels they keep it in
inventory and then they try to sell them
at a higher price it's a different
business model not a better or a worse
it's a different one that's pulling the
margins down Airbnb is never going to
buy your apartment for you pay you up
front and keep it so I don't think they
will enter the Expedia model there's a
story there I'm telling about by Airbnb
but it reflects the business or
businesses I think they're in Revenue
growth margins any questions about the
margins part of your story so what kind
of margins are you going to give on what
are you aspiring to be first they're
making money already right so what are
their margins right now so they're
already pretty solid right Nike's
margins are pretty close right so there
might not be much room on the margins
you're hoping and praying you can hold
on to your margins so almost all all of
their increase has to come from revenue
scaling up and if they introduce a
cheaper shoot to be able to get even
more in revenues you got to build that
in into your margin story saying I will
now be able to double my growth rate but
margins will go to 12% from
15% third and final input and this is
the one that gives me the most trouble
because it's the most shaky number it's
a number where I'm asking for every
dollar of capital I invest how many
dollars of revenues can I get the higher
that number the more efficiently I'm
delivering growth so when I look at the
things that go into it I'll obviously
start with what your history tells me
about so in fact for Airbnb I looked
every year at the change in sales and
the change in invested Capital the
number was like $1.5 of Revenue I was
surprised how low it was because I was
told this is a low Capital intensity
business but it turns out they have to
do Acquisitions and this is the thing to
remember about a lot of technology
companies that claim to be low capital
intensity they don't build factories
they don't have fixed assets but they
have to do Acquisitions just to keep
going Airbnb has done like 25
Acquisitions over their lifetime of
Technologies sub
platforms so they got about one point so
I'm going to look at that if I can I'm
going to look at the business as well
but there are three things about this
company I'm going to look at one is as
they get bigger is it going to get more
easier for them to scale that that sales
Capital will it go up or not in some
businesses it might you could argue that
as you get bigger you can be more
efficiently start to deliver revenues
because you're drawing in your existing
infrastructure if your company is in one
of those businesses you can increase the
sales to Capital ratio over time most
companies though you'd be surprised how
quickly you re hit a
ceiling and so don't take your sales to
Capital ratio of two and make it 17 just
because you feel like it it's very
difficult to pull that
off but once in a while you will be a
able in your company to be able to scale
up with very little invested capital I
talked a little bit about boing in the
last session right so you're valuing
boing you're catching it at a really bad
time in its history they sold fewer
aircraft last year than in
decades why multiple factors let's say
you map out a pathway back to Grace for
boring where their growth is coming from
not just you know increasing aircraft to
some high number but going back to pre
2000 pre 737 max levels you put in a 20%
growth right which will in about 5 years
get them do you need any
reinvestment relatively little why
because their existing you know if you
look at their assembly lines and plans
are they have more than 50% excess
capacity this will actually be using the
excess capacity you might have to R too
so if you give me a really high sales to
Capital ratio for the next five years
I'm going to step back and say you know
what that makes sense this is something
I run into with Tesla with each new
Factory they build right after they
build a factory they get about a three
or four year window where they can grow
with relatively little
reinvestment so when I they only had the
Fremont plant I had to think about new
plants now they you know they have a
plant every two or three years you get
this window where you can grow and it's
a limited window it's not forever where
you can give them a high sales Capital
ratio
yes reinvestment is all of it so don't
ever break it down reinvestment is all
you know net cap change in working
capital so if you have a very high
working capital driven business it just
means you'll have no scaling up effects
as you grow and everything has to grow
with it so it's captured all in that
number right so my reinvestment is
everything Acquisitions net capex change
in working capital so look at your
business model and see what drives it
maybe for on it's a working capital it's
a big part of invested Capital worst
part about that it's very difficult to
break out of that cycle right as you
grow your invested Capital has to grow
with it and finally there are some
businesses where there's a lag between
when you reinvest and when you grow
let's take no NOK fastest growing large
farmer company right now driven by
what OIC and
wovi when did they do the R&D for zic
and wovi decade ago for a diabetes drug
right this is purely providential it
turned out that you lost weight if
you're valuing a farmer company you see
what this is going to mean right the
sales to Capital ratio will not be wased
on the change in revenues this year
it'll be the change in revenues 10 years
from now and even 10 years from now your
compan is going to be a mature company
you can live off past fat for a while
and if you look at why Eli Lily is
priced the way it is because they've
been successful with the Obesity drugs
they've done the hard work already so
you can give them a high sales to cap
ratio low reinvestment and still give
them high growth
rates so in the case of Airbnb I did
give them a sales to Capital ratio of
two roughly where they are because I
don't see a scaling benefit here that's
going to kick in on the reinvestment
side what is that mean I take the change
in revenues each year of just their
revenues not the gross
bookings and I divide by two and I'm
done that's my reinvestment eacher the
end result is you look at my free cash
flows of firm this is in my upbeat
optimis story there are my free cash
flows the next 6 years negative negative
negative
eventually the numbers turn you need
that for value is this a pessimistic
view it's incredibly optimistic view but
because I'm so optimistic the cash flows
are actually more
negative the pharmaceutical company how
do
you the
regulation the pricing right right
because what once you developed a drug
you got to sell it the reason us
pharmaceutical business is so much more
valuable than the pharmaceutical
business elsewhere in the world is not
Demand right there are far more need
there's far higher need for insulin in
India because there are more people on
the face of the Earth but in India I
think an insulin dose could cost you $2
$3 here with the even with the price
caps was like 3840 this is a business
where there's pricing power which we all
complain about in healthcare because it
is the cost to us and that pricing power
is what keeps these companies valuable
so you show it as higher margins for a
company where which has pricing power
than for a company that doesn't that's
why Niche farmer companies can end up
with really high margins because you're
and it sounds morbid but you're going
after a small portion of the population
you can charge outlandish prices and get
away with it I'm not talking Martin
Shelli business model if you have no
idea what I'm talking about type in
Martin Shelli into Google and you'll
find out but I'm talking even legitimate
farmer businesses are built on pricing
power in in fact one more thing as you
reinvest something we don't think about
reinvestment is actually a delta in
invested Capital so you can actually
track what you're doing to your invested
Capital over time and because your after
tax operate income is coming from your
Revenue growth and margins you can
compute what I call an imputed return on
Capital saying what am I going to do
with it you're building a company in
your spreadsheet here right you got to
ask yourself can I live with the company
I've created this kind of gives you a
sanity check that's why in the Excel
spreadsheet I send you I computed your
imp imputed return on Capital over 10 if
you get a 5,000% return on Capital in
your 10 there's a message in your
spreadsheet what's the message you're
getting you're not reinvesting enough
how do you fix it Go lower your sales to
Capital ratio there's feedback loops in
your spreadsheet that if you're
listening to you can make your valuation
much more
robust one final Point whenever we talk
about return on capital or sales to
Capital or whatever other number you do
in valuation you're talking about
marginal numbers you know what I mean by
that it's what you will earn on your new
projects not what you've historically
earned only problem is all our data is
based on aggregated data for the whole
company and that can sometimes be
deceptive and here why let's say have a
company the 25% return on Capital that's
total after tax operate income divide by
total invested Capital right but if I
look looked at what they actually took
last year as projects is it possible
they earn a return Capital well below
25%
absolutely and what's hiding it the fact
that you have this great and glorious
history Coca-Cola could take terrible
Investments for the next 5 six seven
years you wouldn't even notice it till
you get your six or seven because they
have such a legacy return on Capital to
build on so when you think about
marginal returns there a way to compute
it but it's incredibly noisy I actually
reporting that EX in the Ginsu
spreadsheet that take the change in
revenue and change in invested Capital
it's all over the place but they might
be a pattern if you can compute it over
time to see if your company is moving
away from or towards this historical
return on
Capital brings me to the last piece of
the
puzzle first let's be clear why do we
need a terminal value to get closure we
can't estimate cash flows forever so
it's your cash flows are in perpetuity
saying what do I do you stop in your
five or 10 you estimate a terminal value
right and if you accept that that's why
we have it then the question becomes how
exactly do you get there so let me lay
out the four approaches including the
one I said should not be done the first
three are all intrinsic value approaches
they're perfectly compatible you can do
liquidation value how do you get the
liquidation value of a company what
would you
do any
ideas look at what the they own and if
it's land and building and Equipment you
got lucky land and building especially
it's real estate if it's patn you got a
little Messier analysis but liquidation
values think of it as eBay basically
you're taking your company you're
putting every asset on eBay and getting
the best price you
have liquidation value for finite life
companies of companies where there's a
personal component to the business where
when that person passes on the business
dies liquidation works good for going
concern you can either have the
perpetuity which is what we tend to see
in most textbooks including mine or and
I think we need to emphasize I need to
emphasize this more in my textbooks that
you can compute terminal value by
assuming that you get to your 10 and
then you have 20 more years of cash
flows because your technology is going
to die after 20 years it's a present
value
problem and as I mentioned the one way
you cannot do this is to take your
terminal year whatever number Revenue e
and the reason has is is not that it's a
bad thing or a good thing it makes your
biggest intrinsic value number into a
pricing you have a forward
pricing and you create the charade the
front end of cash flows so I'm going to
put in a series of guard rails on
intrinsic value calculations that
hopefully if you follow you will not get
into those side alleys that analysts
often get into first let's stay with the
Perpetual growth model cash flow in the
next period divide by R minus J right
you get to year 10 you get the cash flow
in year 11 it's always has to be one one
year after why is
that it's a present value rule present
value needs next year's cash flow not
this year so it's not specific to
terminal value it's any kind of present
value equation the First Cash Flow
should be one year from now so to get
the year 10 terminal value you need year
11's cash flow divide by Rus C take a
look at the
denominator because that's the most
dangerous place valuation right R minus
G and if you if I let you play with the
G you're going to get your terminal
value to whatever number you want but
this is a growth rate you're going to be
able to maintain in perpetuity let me
lay some know set some rules on the
table you tell me whether you agree with
them this growth rate cannot cannot
exceed the growth rate of the economy in
urine it's a matsh right this is not a
finance rule it's not an economics rule
you can't let one number grow at a
higher rate than the other number
because that first number is going to
become larger than the second number
your company will become the economy
should it be nominal terms or real terms
you'd be surprised how often I get asked
this question when I get to stable
growth should I go to use a real growth
rate forever or a nominal growth rate
what's the answer for
that ask them what they've done for the
first 10 years because by the time you
got to year 10 you did something for the
first 10 years right did you do ninal
cash flows if you if you did ninal you
got to stay with normal if you did real
cash flows you do real what currency
well he chose again right you did your
cash flows in dollars for the first 10
years don't switch to Euro growth rates
it's got to be in the same
currency so it's a consistency issue now
of course I've replaced one problem with
another one right because now value a
company what do you have to do project
out what the growth rate will be in the
global economy in US dollar terms after
2035 good luck on that one you know how
much time spend on trying to get this
number
finessed what's the right answer if in
fact you go down this there's zero
chance you can reason your way to a
number so I'm going to use a shortcut
that works for me you're welcome to use
it you're welcome to abandon it and I'll
tell you why I use it when I get to year
five or year 10 my cash flows and I want
to put my company at a stable growth
rate I put a cap on that growth rate and
my cap is my risk free rate remember
this valuation has a risk free rate in
the denominator
let me explain my justification for this
I don't know whether any of you remember
this equation called the Fisher equation
I saw it in my econ class way back in
time Fisher equation is actually very
simple it says a noral interest rate is
composed of two numbers an expected
inflation rate and an expected real
interest
rate what's a nominal growth rate in the
economy expected inflation rate plus an
expected real growth rate right set the
equations next to each other the
expected inflation cancel out the
question becomes what is the
relationship between real interest rates
and real growth
rates I'll tell you how I was start real
interest rates in my econ
class my professor kept talking about
apples he said if you borrow 100 apples
today you got to return 102 apples a
year from now you know why when you talk
about real interest rates you have to
talk in terms of goods and services
rather than dollars is you're borrowing
something today you're returning it a
year from now a real interest rate is in
terms of real goods and services and
that actually is going to allow me to
break this deadlock let's say I go
around promising people a 3% real
interest rate but my economy is growing
in real terms by only
2% I'm going to have a problem you see
what what it is where the heck am I
going to make up that extra
1% so your real interest rate cannot be
greater than the real growth rate in the
long term because things are going to
blow up the other side is a little more
difficult to prove can a real interest
rate be less than the real growth rate
for extended periods but eventually the
real interest rate will start creeping
up because there's s so much room in the
economy to make great Investments people
will start to desire to consume more now
so either direction there's convergence
between the two numbers and when you get
to the terminal value you don't need
this to happen next year two years from
now but eventually it's going to happen
you're not convinced I can tell so I'm
going to try a second
pl we want a ninal growth rate in the
economy right so here's the experiment I
ran I went back in time to 1954 looked
up the t- bond rate at the start of each
year looked at the ninal growth rate in
the next 10 years I was trying to figure
out is the t- bond rate a good predictor
of normal growth and for the last 50
years I was able to run a contest of the
t- bond rate versus the consensus growth
rate you got from the 50 top economists
in the
US this is no
contest you know which metric went out
con you know continuously over the the T
bond rate was a far better predictor of
nominal growth rate in the economy than
the 50 top economists in the country
with all of their tools and their models
and I'm not
surprised here's the problem when you
get four cast tting from economists or
Market timers there's no money behind I
can get on CNB saying I think the
economy will grow 6% a
year what if I'm wrong doesn't really
matter I'm not going when you're in the
bond market I'm asking you to put money
behind your backing and the t- bond rate
is backed up by trillions of dollars of
money so I'm not surprised that t-bond
rates are better predictors of noral
growth so if you don't buy to the Fisher
equation argument maybe the empirical
argument does prettyy well in terms of
and that's actually terrible news if
you're in an economy with negative
interest rates right because what is the
bond market sending as a message
deflation and negative
growth and that's basically more likely
to be true than not if the history holds
on if you're not convinced by that
either I have a third argument for why
the risk free rate is a good proxy
valuation is all about being consistent
you get to your year 10 or year 11
you estimate a risk free rate you also
estimate a growth rate in perpetuity
right could it be is it possible
interest rates are too low yeah it could
be but if interest rates are too low you
know what you do you also keep growth
rates low and if you're wrong in the
same direction in both it cancels
out if interest rates are too high again
not a problem discount rate will be too
high but I'll give you a higher growth
rate it keeps your valuations from going
off the rails
this was a big issue in the last decade
because as you know Le three or four
currencies had negative risk- free rates
Euro the Swiss frank the Japanese Y and
it freak people up and here's the
reasoning they said if risk-free rates
turn negative my valuations are going to
become really really high do you see the
reason for that right risk free rates
become negative you have a low cost of
capital and if I use the growth rates
I've historically been using 2 3 4% my
valuations are blowing up and that
constantly push and they would try to
normalize risk Rees and do neat things
with it so there's an easier fix here
and I'll show you what the fixes by
showing a valuation I did of
hinin in September of
2019 I did this in Munich and there were
three people in the audience from the
hinin finance group so initially when I
went through the cost of capital they
were actually very happy that I left the
risk free rate where it was minus .5%
why because it gave them a cost of
capital of about 5%
see patting each other back this is a
great word we live it then I got to the
numerator and I had to estimate growth
and remember what's the message I'm
getting from the negative three R you're
living in a deflationary low growth
economy so I gave them a low growth rate
3% year were a little disappointed but
what I did on the terminal value freaked
them out when I got to the teral value
take a look at the growth rate I assumed
in
perpetuity I'm following this Ru Capital
the RIS rate I gave them a minus5 and
they said this is not fair I said you
weren't complaining when I gave you a
really low cost of capital right what
one hand gives you the other hand takes
away in spite of risk-free rates being
negative hinin came out as overv Valu so
it cuts against the grain of low risk
free rates are good because the cash
flows are actually worse affected than
the discount rate by this
phenomenon so as long as you connect
your risk free rate your growth rates
your ter what got people into trouble in
the last decade is they continue to use
growth rates in the terminal value based
on what they learned in school in the
1990s or what they learned of their jobs
in the previous decade while lowering
the risk free rate to what it was in
2017 18 192 that's a
mismatch that can cause your terminal
value to explode yes Jacob but like in
the US currently the 10e T bond is like
4 and a half% you're saying 4 and half
that's your cap it doesn't have to be
that the growth rate is at 4 and a half%
right that's your cap you can give any
number lower but you can't go above 4
and a half% you saying what if it's just
a little bit more no still not right you
still need to give away the cap so
obviously you get a lot more room on
your stable growth rate now than you did
three years ago and rates 1 and a half%
but it also comes with the catch right
you now have a much higher discount rate
you're going to be using for that
terminal value and a much higher
discount to bring the terminal value
back net are you better off or worse off
I'm not sure right so it kind of cuts
both ways and that's the way it should
be it's kind of know compensating
effects in your cash flows and your
discount
rates so your valuing on one of the
question you're going to face is when
will my company be a mature company and
on has 800 million in revenues the
business is huge it's well regarded now
and you're saying can I give it a 25
year growth period can I give a 20- year
growth and often with companies that are
Star companies young companies you why
can't I give it 15 20 25 years okay so
here are a couple of things to keep in
mind as to how long you can let your
company grow before things start to
mature first is if you're a small
company in a very large Market clearly
you have more room to wait longer till
you make your company mature on can grow
for a long time not end up dominating
the market but also remember growth
creat value only if you earn more than
your cost to Capital so the other half
of this picture you're asking is not
just whether I can grow but whether I
can earn a return that exceeds my cost
of capital and that is tied to what kind
of sustainable advantages you have as a
company we'll talk more and more about
storytelling for your company but part
of your story has to be about what
happens after your attent does your
company become a commoditized company
earning its cost to Capital or is a
company like Coca-Cola or amen that
might have competitive advantage that
spill over forever because that's going
to determine whether you can keep the
return on capital above the cost of
capital so as you think about you know
how long don't wait too long most
companies buture far faster than you
then so about 20 you know 30 or 40 years
ago I started collecting data and growth
companies I've never updated them too
lazy and I just chronicled how long
growth lasted at a typical us Growth
Company
3 to 5 years before you kind of become
very much like the industry you say but
there are companies out there that have
grown for more than 5 years absolutely
and we can name any of these companies
that have grown for long periods which
tells you a lot about the exception not
the
rule third remember that when you put in
a growth rate or change the growth
terminal value something has to change
in the
numerator and to show you the effect of
this I took that example we started with
remember $100 million after tax
operating 10% cost of capital and I said
what if the growth rate is 2% with a
growth rate of 2% you know what the
value would be a billion dollars if the
return on capital is equal to the cost
of capital could it be higher than a
billion not because the growth is high
but because you earn more than the cost
of capital if you're a bad business and
I putting a 2% growth rate in your
terminal value calculation I will
demolish your terminal value each time I
raise the growth rate cuz what you will
lose in the numerator will be far
greater than what you give what you gain
in the
denominator so when analyst push back
and say this growth assumption my
terminal value making a huge effect in
value they're already confessing to what
they're doing right what are they doing
they taking the terminal value keeping
everything in it fixed and taking the
growth rate from 1 to two to two and a
half to three of course your value is
exploding because you're creating growth
magic you're putting in a growth rate
without telling me what happens to your
cash flows
now my my valuation book was published
in 198 my very first valuation book came
out in the late 1980s perhaps 1998
around the same time that McKenzie's
valuation book also came out and they
were both published by John Wy and the
McKenzie valuation book you get to the
terminal value chapter the terminal
value at least in the original version
of the book was no plat which is just
ebit * 1- they invented this word no
plat for it divide by cost of capital
there was no growth in the
equation for years I would get emails
from people reading the McKenzie book
saying I'm reading the terminal value
chapter I noticed there is no growth in
the terminal value why which my response
is why aren't you writing to McKenzie
why you writing to me but we both
published they thought I probably hung
out at a bar with the McKenzie guys and
we chatted about terminal value all day
hugely depressing thought if you think
about it
but I you the reason was actually in the
book what McKenzie assumed is once you
get to stable growth you earn your cost
of capital and the reasoning is in the
long term no company earns more than its
cost of capital therefore you get to
year 10 we're going to make the return
and if you make the return on Capital
equal to the cost of capital what do we
say about growth it doesn't matter so
might as well use a zero growth
rate but McKenzie in its own research
came up with data that countered the
assump they were making in the valuation
a publication from McKenzie called
McKenzie quar it's a great publication
it's free it's of lower quality than it
used to be because it does a lot of
crappy stuff in the middle but you know
they have lots of data proprietary data
from their clients that they look at to
answer questions so one of the questions
they were looking at is if you track
companies over time what happens to the
growth rate no surprise as you track
them the growth rate starts to move
towards the growth rate of the economy
which is what we assume then there has a
question as you track companies over
time what happens with return on Capital
and notice the return on Capital doesn't
drop to the cost of capital in the real
world there are quite a few companies
out there that earn well above the cost
of capital and will continue to do so
for
decades partly because of existing
Investments that are not going to become
neutral Investments at the end of year
10 I don't like the McKenzie Assumption
of return on capital is equal to cost of
capital for every mature company because
it takes away degree of freedom I want
to maintain in my story when I value
Coca-Cola I want to give Coca-Cola this
is the only way I can reward great
companies when I get to your 10 right I
can't let them grow a rate faster than
the economy but I can give them Returns
on Capital that are in excess of the
cost of capital but that has to then
become part of my story what is it about
this company that will give it long
sustainable
advantages I know how many of you worked
in private company appraise or even
public companies I'm going to give you a
collection of
assumptions that you will see all the
time in real world valuation so you have
a analyst projecting cash flow the next
10 years at the end of year 10 they'll
tell you the company is a mature company
so far so good right they say it grows
at 2% a year is that okay right now yeah
4.7% is the cap 2% is fine and then they
would say because it's a mature company
I am going to assume I being the analyst
I'm going to assume that capex offsets
depreciation what's what what does it
what does that make Net
capex Zero and working capital
requirements are negligible which makes
a change in working capital Zer what's 0
plus 0 Z what's 0 divided by any number
zero so the reinvestment rate is zero
you see the the the these are valuation
models that are built to blow up what's
the inconsistency you've assumed a zero
reinvestment rate and you're telling me
and of course the push back you get is
but what if I said it at the inflation
rate sounds alluring right because you
don't need excess capacity what's the
problem with even if it's just the
inflation
rate no you can't make the cost of
capital it's got to be a reinvestment
rate what is reinvestment when you say
the capex offset depreciation what are
you doing you're replacing old machines
with new machines you're not building
new capacity right and if you have
inflation helping you on the
revenues guess what it doesn't go away
when you replace the old machine you
said look you know what the inflation is
only for my Revenue stuff it's no your
same machine will cost you more which
effectively means even if you grow just
at the inflation rate this reinvestment
assumption will still kick in There's No
Escape Hatcher if anybody tells you they
can have zero reinvestment and growth
that's valuation m practice there is no
justification for it but people do it
all the time so now you have the
ammunition the next time you run into
this combination about half of all DCFS
I see have this combination and they're
able to get away with it now push back
finally what are you doing to your
company you're making it a mature
company right what does that mean you're
bringing your growth rate down that's a
bad news but is there any good news to
being
middle-aged you
see first you have more wealth so you're
more stable
right which your cost of capital will
show up as a cost of capital
decreasing now you also can probably
have a more settled set of return on
Capital so but so what I'm trying to say
is if you make your growth rate when you
make your company mature company not
just the growth rate that changes your
cost of capital should start to move
towards the cost of capital of a typical
company that's why I do that histogram
of cost of capital median cost of
capital 9 so as I look at the know year
10 I'm trying to push your company
towards a
media will your return on Capital
probably decrease as you get probably
you're a great company you're going to
become less great doesn't mean you're
cost you get to the cost of capital but
you're earning a 30% return on Capital
now I can almost guarantee you that if
you scale up fivefold that that return
on capital is going to come under
pressure you're going to move it towards
the cost of
capital and because your growth rate is
much lower you can't this is exactly why
you can't take your year 10 cash flow
and put a 1 plus G on it to get your
cash flow year Lev you're looking at me
like that's what I was planning to do
what's the problem with taking year 10
cash flow and putting a One Plus on it
you're taking the reinvestment rate you
had in year 10 and essentially locking
it in for perpetuity right so let's say
a growth rate in your 10 is 5% and
beyond your 10 it's going to be
2% you need to recompute your
reinvestment rate for your terminal
value calculation cuz you 10 number will
give you too lower cash flow give your
company the characteristics of a mature
company and if you do that effectively
it's going to play out last piece and
this is just a kind of wrapping up piece
lots of talked about lots of different
ways you can value a company right let's
look at the choices you can you know at
this stage you got cash flows you got
growth rate cost of equity but he's
saying which cash flow should I discount
dividends free cash Equity free cash for
the firm which disc discount rate should
we use cost of equity cost of capital
what kind of growth pattern should I add
when I think about valuation I think of
three big boxes of Lego that you're
trying to put together to get different
discounted cash flow models so let's
start with the first block which cash
flow should I
discount for firms which have stable
leverage they probably better off using
Equity because you can do the shortcut
to get to free cash
R which means for most of you what do I
mean by stable leverage you have a debt
ratio to and you think your company's
going to stay at that debt ratio in
perpetuity you do conad yeah probably
stuck in the ways you do on and you put
in the debt ratio today make it the debt
ratio for you're probably going to be in
trouble right so when you and for
financial service clubs and we'll talk
about why you end up with Equity
valuation alone for financial service
flubs for everybody else it's better off
Val the entire
firm so let's say you come to this fork
in the road you've decided to go the
equity valuation route there are two
cash flows you can discount in equity
right you can use the dividend discount
model or the free cash Equity model so
with which one should I
pick if the dividenden it's not stable
go if it's stable you going to take the
dividends you you're going to walk right
into a trap there right because every
Dividends are always stable why the
stable because they're sticky right it's
not that whether they're stable but
whether they reflect my free cash FL
Equity if a company pays out roughly
what it can afford to which also means
then then might as well use a free cash
Equity model right unless you cannot
estimate free cash flow Equity you say
why would I not be able to do it I've
taken this class remind me again what I
need for free cash FL Equity I need net
income and add depreciation subtract
capex subtract change in working capital
and subtract change in debt
I'll give
you an assignment take any bank and I
challenge you to estimate the free
cashlo equity for a bank net income you
can get right but everything below it I
have no idea what's amortization for a
bank what's capex for a bank what's
working capital for a bank what's debt
issuances and debt repayments for a bank
so for as long as we've been doing
valuation people give up on banks they I
can't estimate free cash Lo Equity so
what are you left with desperation you
do the dividend discount because you've
given up and I'll make a confession
until 2008 that's what I did I no longer
do it because I think we can dig
ourselves into a hole when we use the
dividend discount model but that's why
we use dividends it's not because we
think that some are better for banks but
because we can't estimate free cash so
second fork in the road Equity value
free cash if you can estimate free cash
Equity just stay with the free cash or
Equity
model what discount rate should I
use well I've already chosen the cash
flow right right the discount rate is
really not even a choice you pick the
the the cash flows to be cash flows to
equity your discount rate has to be cost
of equity remember can CAU and first
Boston cash flow to the firm cost to
Capital what currency again tell me what
currency did the cash flows in so the
discount rate choice is out of your
hands once you made the cash flow choice
and final
piece can I get away using a stable
growth model can you what kinds of
companies you know some of you might
have picked these companies what has
what are you going to check to see if
you can because a stable growth model
means you don't need the front end of 10
years of cash flows you can just go
right now and get cash flow next year R
minus G you can be done with your DCF
valuation in 5 minutes you say I'm
tempted I'm going to take my
company first it has to be a stable
Growth Company so what's what are you
going to check the growth rate to see if
it's less than the risk Freer right be
few hundred companies in the US but
that's good second stop you got to look
to see if it's behaving like a stable
Growth Company in what sense if this
company is reinvesting a lot no matter
what the growth rate it thinks it can
have higher growth that gets in the way
your margin have everything has to have
settled
in I'll say one in 25 companies I look
at stable Growth Company I can just go
directly to the terminal value equation
conet I'm going to Value later on the
class with a stable growth
model but if you have any growth that
still rece idual there for even mature
companies have some growth Levi Strauss
is a mature company but it has potential
growth in Asia Asians don't wear as you
know genes as much as the rest of the
world maybe it can convince them that
could give you a little growth but for
that's a two-stage model and if every
other company you need some kind of a
transition two-stage models work fine if
you have 7% growth for the next 5 years
and you're going to make it 3% but you
have 70% growth going from 70 to 3 it's
a little too much to ask you create a
transition ultimately every discounted
cash flow model you see out there so
when people talk about hundreds of DCF
models break it down what's the cash
flow what's a discount rate what's the
growth patter right it's the same model
playing out in different
disguises so I'm going to stop there
when we start on Monday we're going to
talk about the loose end you have
everything you need to do your basic
discounted cash flow valuations so I'll
I'll send you that Excel spreadsheet
again because as I said I'd like you to
use my spreadsheet not because it's
better but this is the time to kind of
you know while the while the iron is
still hot basically know do your
valuation do a first round and then you
can
always
so
to just
I would think that
so
I rather than go all the way
and then allow
it care
discount rate
when stage
it's
truey
I can borrow money pay divs right I
can in your
application and
fre hope and that it's to equity I talk
about Equity now
for okay and other question on the
terminal
free see I mean most of the time like
Bankers they do this Dee
equal so T that
okay because you haven't put in
any two days before you can't
selectively
maity but there's inflat there should be
inflation in that item as
well it's not a good justification for
notif okay so I use
reinvest I can I'll do that
then don't say being conservative
and what a lot
of
e
e e